[Music]
do I believe the Bigfoot has been living
in the woods of southwestern
Pennsylvania of course we put together a
team of three and we are single-handedly
going to find Bigfoot in these woods
behind me this is what I like to call
the Squatch cam essentially holidays as
a Joby Gorillapod attached to my head
with a camera mounted on top and with a
camo covering so the Squatch will never
even be able to see this now I wear this
thing all the time I wear when I'm
sleeping I wear it when I'm working out
I wear it when I'm eating dinner because
I never know when I'm gonna see
sasquatch
he can appear at any time the last time
I saw him it was a Walmart and I tracked
him all the way here so I know a lot of
people have been searching for Bigfoot
for a very long time but you know what
they're not doing the things that we're
doing do you know what they're not
searching with the things that we're
searching with I have a Squatch sack and
this sack contains all of the things
essential to catching Bigfoot let's take
a look here are my Squatch sack I have
messed a sunrise Squatch love's mess a
sunrise especially because it's all
organic an iPad this is necessary
because there's this thing called Google
Maps and with Google Maps I am able to
track a lot of things so this is the
Squatch stop once we find him we're
going to tie him up and he's not going
anywhere we're gonna get him I've also
got some Nestle Tollhouse chocolate
chips there's a little known fact that
you guys might not know but I know it
sasquatch that's chocolate look I'll be
honest with y'all I just need to work I
found I found these two stupid girls on
Greg the Internet may look like arm
exercises to you he's actually a Squatch
call to them you know they said they was
looking for somebody to carry their
their gear and and lug heavy stuff and
just in case they found you know a
sasquatch that they could I could hold
them down
and you know get the shackles on him and
stuff everyone thinks the Bigfoot is
this big cuddly creature let me tell you
about no he's not
this one time I got this close this
close and let me tell you what he left
me with he left me with a squash scratch
look at this do you see that I mean come
on let's face it even an idiot knows a
day no such thing as the Bigfoot cuz I
got big feet already
I know so oh you see my friend so so so
here's what I do see I don't ever want
to be out of work so I got this big bear
looks kind of like a sasquatch right I
like to take this guy and I like to hide
in places and then make a little call
off in the distance and I think it's a
sasquatch
so they go run around and take our
pictures and they keep searching
something I need to show you
I found this it's fresh fresh Squatch
poo come on not here look at this oh my
gosh I think I heard him I think I heard
him I think I heard him never mind it
was just the cattle next door let's take
back to this what I'm noticing can you
get it can you get a little closer do
you see those bugs in there do you know
what that means do you know what that
means that means this person Squatch pit
was fresh and I still got a job you may
notice some type of contraption behind
me that's the Squatch feeder in the
Squatch feeder we usually put things
like cereal Mesa sunrise the nestle
chips all kinds of things we try to lure
them in I think it goes off about every
half an hour
the squatches love it we just need to
catch one on camera now
[Music]
and then when they're off shooting some
other thing I can come back make them
think I'm helping them watch it so you
need me to carry anything or do anything
or yell stand back
you got it got teasing a little bit oh
don't got a tuning instrument I'll
follow with the camera okay let's go
let's go
he's Kurt's assess you know it's further
back further back I heard him keep going
well we have here is a squash mobile the
problem with a lot of people hunting for
Bigfoot is they don't have one of these
and what we also have here is camouflage
Squatch won't even see what's coming
let's go carry on
[Music]
I'm all alone I'm all alone a must-watch
mobile
[Music]